tout, des gymnases aux églises et aux
soirées de massage, chaque magasin,
nous avons même le marché de Noël qui se
déroule à nottingham juste devant
notre porte,
tous autorisés à aller de l'avant alors que nous
devons rester sûrs
[Musique]
nous n'avons pas de cuisine donc il y a  aucune
opportunité de le faire
et donc euh nous avons regardé d'autres façons euh toutes
les autres entreprises et lieux qui peuvent
s'ouvrir
euh sous toutes les larmes un lieu de
culte était l'un d'entre eux donc nous avons euh
enregistré euh enregistré le lieu comme un
nous '  j'ai envoyé une demande pour
enregistrer le lieu comme lieu de culte
euh comme l'église des 400 lapins
[Musique]
nous ne nous attendons pas euh à l'attendre de si
tôt
jetez-le directement dedans